here to respond from West Palm Beach is
Ann Coulter and I know you don't watch
this show I don't either
it's a way political and I don't I don't
watch any of these shows but what goes
through your mind when you see this this
on NBC which just had to jettison its
big anchor Matt Lauer after you know all
the stories came out about him and women
and now this storyline well I heard
about it when I got in last night my
fans were mostly upset that they thought
the actress didn't do my me justice god
bless my fans and you know I mean there
were three direct quotes from me or at
least lies about things I'd said so yeah
it was pretty clearly supposed to being
me I don't care could not care less I
know it would be much better TV if I
didn't care and I was indignant but it
could be sort of a public service
announcement this is how you react I'm
not like the berkeley students who
thought it was a personal assault if Ann
Coulter gave a speech on their campus by
smashing windows and threatening to burn
the place down and in fact Laura I did
not break a single window since hearing
about this show it is I mean there are
two things that I haven't seen any that
I just heard that segment I but it's
funny how liberals always think were as
precious as they are I mean just that
that woman who's talking my gather was
supposed to make be me know that's how
liberals talk they are constantly in a
state of outrage come to one of my
speeches but a see that's not my
approach and imagine if there was a
storyline about some politically correct
figure being raped brutally with you
know with a very familiar story line
connected to aid I know so I can't think
a Muslim commentator or something I just
don't think people would kind of look
the other way I think it would create a
huge conversation right I mean it would
run Islamophobic how dare you bring this
Robin this is far this is making my life
more dangerous right no I mean seriously
me giving a speech the the main import
of which was going to be federal law we
should enforce it
no that was enough to threaten to burn
the campus down and have Li cancel me
and most college campuses but really I
mean people are being thrown off Twitter
remember I think Milo was thrown off
Twitter for calling an actress ugly so
I'm thinking why don't they follow my
approach and and not care but I do think
it's worth bringing up at this point
also what just raging frauds and
hypocrites they are I mean put one of
the one of the things was that this
character I mean I read it and the news
Buster's write up wants to deport
dreamers okay Laura I promise you the
writers the actors the producers of this
TV show they have it will move heaven
and earth to make sure their kids don't
go to school any place near a dreamer
their only contact with illegal aliens
is the woman who cleans their toilet
whose name they don't know oh but
they're going to stand up for the
illegal aliens know so much about of
Hollywood is just wanting to feel
morally superior to conservatives in
particularly to Trump voters well and I
thought I thought the the show it was
another reminder of why it's so good to
read and not watch certain shows on
television except the shows the shows
like this where you can actually get a
laugh maybe learn a little something and
thanks so much